hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a remote section
we are back uh to provide some some a's
to your queues
question number
one the discord's essay club awesome
incidentally the discord's essay club
discussed derek bell's serving two
masters which is actual crt not pop crt
criticalize theory
bell suggests so this is not an essay
that i have read although from this
question i think i should it sounds
interesting
bell suggests in this essay again
serving two masters that in brown versus
board of education rather than ending
the separateness of quote separate but
equal we could have cashed the but equal
promissory note improved black schools
instead of forced integration
if we accept inarguendo not a phrase
i've heard before but i like it if we
accept inarguendo that this would have
been better for black students than
integration and busing how do we think
about the morality of these still
unequal separate but improved scenario
i'm trying to parse that last sentence
um
i mean i i sort of feel like
it was separate
that's bad
but it's separate as a result of
frankly
uh
separation
in where people live right so the point
is it's symptomatically separate
unequal is a downstream consequence of
the fact that we at least in part
collect
tax revenue locally and then spend it on
schools so poor neighborhoods have less
to spend
that's obviously a structural bias with
very serious consequences
but
the final punch line of the whole thing
is that the entire educational system is
failing across the board and so
therefore you know
it all needs a rethink yeah i mean
that's all true and not at all
responsive to whatever we can understand
the question to me and i i guess i would
also say that
it is well known as well established and
you have just alluded to the fact that
your zip code the zip code in which you
grow up
is extraordinarily predictive of
educational outcomes
and therefore um ultimately
uh sort of job and quality of life
outcomes and this is not um
that means that we do not have a quality
of opportunity
but it is also true you can t you can
take it farther back than that and say
well um you know because of
um largely historical i'm not saying
that there is no systemic racism left
but largely historic systemic historical
systemic racism true that
um african-american families for
instance have my and i don't have the
stats in front of me but much lower
accumulated family wealth than do say
white families in the u.s
and so it is that
much lower community family wealth that
um then
is at least largely explanatory for why
um there you have uh
african-american families um with you
know
those with the greatest of intentions
and educational aspirations unable to
live in neighborhoods where the schools
are good and being trapped in
neighborhoods where the zip codes are
predictive of poor schools and therefore
poor educational outcomes and then you
know and you know and then you know to
go back to
where you excuse me where you ended and
where we started and where you ended
just now and where we started in the
first hour
is uh you know the unfortunate truth
that all education across you know all
socio-economic sectors now um is failing
in different ways in different places
but it's all failing yeah it's not going
to fail to deliver the elite to the next
class of elite right but it's failing to
upgrade mines
um but you know what we haven't done is
address this um
you know
could could we not do a better job of as
in the language of derek who's asked the
question cashing the but equal
promissory note um improving black
schools instead of forcing integration
yeah in fact uh i've made the argument
that
the case for reparations is strongest
for
american blacks and american indians but
that i don't think the case is very
strong at all for
cash payments it's right
the cases for investment in communities
in the systems that actually do have an
effect a causal effect on um quality of
life and ability to succeed i want to be
cautious here
i don't think you can't assume by the
fact of unequal outcomes
that it is
these causes i believe it is these
causes that effectively if you do give
people equal opportunity and not just
like hey here's your equal opportunity
but you know a consistent level of
opportunity such that people learn how
to make use of it that people are
fundamentally the same um
and so but that is but i mean family
structure just the degree of family
wealth which in turn is so is correlated
not just with
you know the amount of rent or mortgage
that you can afford um but just you know
the number of books you have in your
home you know the chances that your kid
was read to as a as a kid um and you
know where you read to as a kid um it's
really easy for a you know i say naive
conservative typical argument be like oh
that's because those people don't care
about reading it's like no maybe they
just didn't have access to books well
i'm not i have no trouble with the maybe
and i actually have no trouble with the
belief that actually if you did run the
controlled experiment you would find
that this is causal the problem is which
is causal the uh lack of accumulated
family wealth being predictive of
outcomes because not having the wealth
bars reaching those outcomes i believe
that is true but it is not clear yes you
could reverse cause and effect so i
think that that will turn out to be
false if we ever you know what we'll do
to be
the idea that there is something
inherent to populations that is actually
causal and resulting in less accumulated
wealth i think there's nothing to that
but the point is we can't assume there
is nothing to it
all right
if the u.s is indeed suppressing data of
adverse events from the public
for the vaccines why aren't we seeing
these symptoms show up in data from
other countries like israel
um
i mean i think i i think we at least
were yeah i i i don't accept the premise
of the question yeah i mean you know is
israel had you know
mass
really as close to 100 percent without
being 100 vaccination early and you know
practically simultaneously um of any
country and it's small enough that it
was actually able to take a lot of a lot
of data and then um and then they were
reporting the same kinds of adverse
events uh
early this summer maybe and i don't have
my i don't have the whole timeline and
any of the research in front of me but
um
you know it has since sort of gone back
on to the on to the vaccine bandwagon
but it was very um very becoming very
hesitant uh for a while about boosters
even as as it was becoming clear that um
that boosters would be needed um to
maintain any level of immunity yeah i
think we do have an adverse event signal
what we don't have is systems that allow
you to compare one country to another so
we've got you know the european yellow
card system or the british yellow card
system
you've got the american verse system
israel has a different system
and then you do appear to have a
campaign of suppression of information
and the misfiling of things or at least
the filing of things based on the
assumption you know we are now hearing
about you know
where did i
see a recent report on what explains the
uptick in uh
heart attacks right and you know
obviously this is a complex question on
the other hand we have a prime candidate
and yeah i clear desire not to discuss
uh yeah no that that sort of thing and
then also um i just saw someone
picture on the side of a bus
you know children have strokes too
right the sort of you know the
normalizing of um once
widely understood to be extraordinarily
rare things in children um to be sort of
put out there almost as
trial balloons um in advance of what
maybe
really hope not but what may be an
uptick in strokes and children as uh as
we have a roll out happening here
i don't
remember this movie well enough to know
how to answer this question i do good go
for it
what movie are we talking about
no i want to see what you can
do it's not fair
no it really isn't
is a situation like monsters inc
a parasite feeding on neural energy
possible
uh the parasite feeding on neural energy
like what's the
definition i think
yeah you need to like what
what is energy right like what
in what way
can you parasitize cognition absolutely
um
gad said has a book on this
um yeah but
right but is but it's it's
is it a parasite in the literals yes
metaphor literal ancient meaning like is
is it a
is it a tick or so you know is it
something tick-like as opposed to your
own species parasitizing your cognition
you could let's put it this way both a
literal parasitizing of the energy is
technically possible probably not very
interesting
um and i don't i don't i don't know how
you get there like what parasite is
going to be like
i feel like you need a better could a
life form exist that is fueled by energy
stolen from
cognitive structures
sure i see no reason that couldn't exist
metaphorically speaking something much
more interesting is possible and in fact
should be unarguable that we have this
right i mean for one thing every uh
you know every
boss who takes advantage of the
powerlessness of underlings and their
creativity right you know is
parasitizing mental energy in a sense so
yeah it's it's all possible um but i'd
love to know what the question means
more specifically to be able to answer
it better than that
fair enough
[Music]
my rising birth intervention trend
correlate better with obesity than lazy
doctors
so what i think this means is we talked
about um
doctors
some sometime recently although i don't
honestly remember exactly what the
conversation was but um we talked
recently about the increase in for
instance c-sections and um
i don't know like episiotomies and
epidurals and just like lots of
medicalization of birth
um
and attributing some of it to um
it being easier to schedule and um i'm
not sure i i don't think we use the word
lazy with regard to doctors i think it's
um it's you know it's the business model
it's market driven
uh it's you know of course everyone
would like to you know not be
you know
forced into work in the middle of the
night although frankly if that was one
of your um
key driving
preferences in life perhaps you
shouldn't have become an obstetrician um
it seems seems fairly obvious to me
um because because we are complex
systems we are not you know this this is
not
helping birth is not a process for an
engineer it's a process for a biologist
right um you know to the degree that you
could have a doctor with an engineer's
mentality or a doctor's with a with a
biologist mentality that said
uh is obesity going to make is maternal
obesity likely to make birth harder yes
yes it is so i don't know
we know this to be true although i don't
know to what degree you know
of course you know you're always heavy
at the point that you're you're giving
birth you've always gained some weight
you have to have gained considerable
more weight than the seven to eight
pound baby that you're that you're
carrying um
you know several you know several tens
more pounds than that if you're if
you're healthy but um so what would it
mean to be like you know 40 pounds over
what you're supposed to be as opposed to
a hundred pounds i don't know at what
point it really you really are at more
risk
um because you're heavy yeah but i think
the question uh
imposes a restriction that's unnecessary
and either or
well that it's obesity right what we
have is
increased complexity that comes from
ample nutrition and
oh so metabolic syndrome diabetes but
even even just the fact that um people
in the west even people who are at a
healthy weight in the west are so
thoroughly well nourished and the babies
are so thoroughly well nourished that
the to the degree that the birth of a
human baby is a challenge to a woman her
physiology
um
babies tend to be
larger because the brakes on you know
the baby getting too large are
not as well developed since our
ancestors tended to be resource stressed
but what i don't know
so a fatter baby should not
make for a harder birth it's it's the
head size it's the head circumference
the fat heads you need to watch out for
it's the fat heads you need to watch out
for and i don't know if a um better
nourished mother um gives birth to a
turn a baby at term that has a bigger
head which would be necessary for what
you're talking about to be related to
increased
uh complexity and birth if if the mother
and and until then fetus are simply
well nourished in modern terms well
let's just say there's no
these answers are not mutually exclusive
i do believe that there is a clear
though i haven't didn't know the
question was coming haven't looked into
it but i believe there is a clear trend
towards uh
well-nourished mothers giving birth to
larger babies and therefore there being
a challenge presumably
obesity contributes even another step of
uh complexity and difficulty um as do
sedentary lifestyles that cause
musculature not to be as well developed
all of these things are likely
contributors and the question would be
you know what fraction of the
um the
medicalization is the result of
doctor scheduling stuff around well and
it's not just not even just scheduling
stuff like i'm just thinking about um
at least in
the u.s for hospital births
unless you explicitly
uh unless you go out of your way and you
have to be at the right hospital to be
even be able to do this
birth is lying down
which is um going to be harder on mother
and baby but easier for the attending
staff
and um and you know if you're if you're
hooked up to
ivs or you know or had an epidural or
any number of the ways that um
that medicalization happens now
um you're not going to have an easy time
or you'll maybe be simply stopped from
walking around and actually yes move
your body all the time for sure we say
that all the time but especially in the
run-up to birth like this is going to be
the thing that's going to get you know
get the contractions coming faster and
you know get you to have a birth that is
um going to happen sooner rather than
later which you know once you're in
labor that's what you want
and uh the medicalization uh which
may or may not have to do with you know
laziness or scheduling or obesity or
anything else once you're in that
position it's even harder even more
likely to have a complicated birth once
you've started to complicate it by
restricting the movement of the mother
yep
[Music]
can we cite articles we have not
purchased
in memoriam aaron schwartz
well i don't know if this is an
anniversary or like why that i don't
know why it comes up i mean
it may not be temporal at all it may
just be that uh aaron schwartz was being
pursued for having to liberate articles
that we paid to
produce as citizens who pay taxes and
we're not allowed to see yeah um
can you well first of all i have no
doubt that people regularly cite
articles that they have not read and do
not have not purchased access to
well purchased is different from red yep
i
i cite and read a lot of articles that i
don't purchase sure
um in honor of erin schwartz um
but
i'll just say you know
his efforts uh i don't know to what
degree it's understood as
an academic as an intellectual
um descendant but scihub
which
which i started sort of having to use at
the point that
we lost access to princeton university's
research library
whenever that was last summer
and had been using a little bit in sort
of 2018 as well
actually had been trying to use a lot
was i found it really not not up to the
job and increasingly it is up to the job
and uh
you know we
also there are
some more journals now that are doing
open access
um
or at least limited we'll say you know
you can have x number of of of
peer-reviewed articles um before we
start charging you yep um
people cite articles they don't read all
the time based on hold on they based on
abstracts
obviously that's going to
sometimes be the result of people not
having access to the article and not
pursuing it through scihab
or whatever
uh obviously this is a dumb system if
we're paying for the research not being
able to read it as absurd obviously the
positive feedback that comes from better
resourced institutions having access to
more journals and therefore academics at
those institutions being able to write
papers that are based on a wider read of
the literature is an absurdity yep
positive feedback yeah like everything
else this needs a total rethink yep and
there are you know the sort of the end
runs which are
you know none of the elsevier doesn't
want scihab to exist
but there are sort of intermediate
things and i don't know exactly what the
formal position by elsevier is
across the board for things like what is
it like researchgate and academia
academy.edu i want to say although i'm
not sure that's right but places where
um
researchers themselves authors of
research articles themselves
can put up pdfs of their own work yeah
and so you know if you if you're doing a
search on google scholar
very often
if there's a link to a pdf it will be
through you're not going to get a ci hub
link that way but you'll often get a
research gate or an academia link that
way yeah and it's it's there's there's
an ambiguity here right
you're not allowed to
you know
print off a copy of a copyrighted
book
but
i can buy a book and i can give it or
loan it to you without violating a
copyright can the author of a scientific
work hand it out that's always been
traditional you could write to the
author and they will send you the pdf
and you don't have to pay for it yeah
but digital handouts change the rules
and yeah right um but i think the thing
that is most interesting here what we
should really say is you and i have
again and again said look we are willing
to pay
a fee to simply have access to the kind
of libraries that we had when we were at
michigan for example that's right it
does not appear to be possible and this
is a tremendous mystery because so many
people whether it's
journalists or
you know independent scholars or
whatever need the access and this is one
way it's it's basically an artificial
monopoly on knowledge yes and uh it's
it's
it's disastrous it's despicable and it's
amazing that the market hasn't figured
out that there
is a price that people would be willing
to pay in order to simply have full
access now this is it's it's huge and
you know actually i um i know i
purchased
access to science um just in order to
get their full um
their full rundown every week of what
they think the most important things um
were happening every week were uh and
you know and to be able to read the full
articles because um you know most
those articles aren't going to be
available other ways right away right
you can't
anyone who is in any way a generalist
as a scientific thinker
cannot purchase uh simply go okay well
i'm gonna purchase like the big the
really big ones like science and nature
and also you know the five journals in
my field that i'm covered
that's fine if what you're working on is
so narrow and you've basically said to
yourself and to the world
nothing that is in
any way outside of my very blinded
narrow scope is of interest to me
then yeah you're staying up on the
research such as it is
but
just like roaming the stacks of an
actual physical library allows for
serendipity allows for you to discover
books or journals or whatever it is you
didn't even know existed much less we're
interested in
so too does actually having access to a
world-class library in electronic form
allow you to do searches you know some
of these indexing databases that don't
necessarily have the
have the full text but allow you to do
searches that are more powerful even
than you know the google scholar
searcher at least this was true until a
couple years ago
um and then go oh wow look look at all
of these things across journals that i
may not even heard of
much less i'm going to put down you know
a couple hundred years here's a couple
hundred dollars for a year's
subscription for a journal for whom
there's one article right now that i
think i might be interested in no you
need research university quality access
to libraries and it's astounding that
yes although anyone can buy access to an
individual
journal
if they want for a year and it's not
cheap what you do not appear to be able
to buy at least you didn't the last time
we looked actively into it a year and a
half or two ago
was access
of the sort that you get at an r1
university library at a research
university library and you know if
you're at a lower tier place you have
interlibrary loan agreements often
however the point is it still provides
this massive advantage to the people at
the r1s because
the way research works if you're working
on a general topic as i was doing with
the telomeres where i was dealing with
journals that i'd never read before
because i was in a literature that
wasn't my home turf
right you could
read a paper
you find something
uh important that you need to chase down
and you know you're in this bibliography
you get that paper you're three or four
papers deep before you know what it is
that you're
you know whether this is a fruitful
avenue or not that could be
weeks down the road if you're doing it
through interlibrary loan whereas it
could be an hour down the road if you're
doing it looking at the papers and able
to source them academic electronically
that's right and this is actually
at least at the point that we left
evergreen
it was the case that
in washington state unlike in california
all of the public institutions in the
state did not get access to the
electronic library resources of the
flagship institution the flagship public
institution which is university of
washington so in california
no matter what community college you're
at or cal state university or uc
university you're at if you are a you
know faculty staff student at any public
institution of higher ed two-year
four-year doctorate undergraduate
whatever
in california you have access to the
electronic library database for the
entire system
whether or not you've ever set foot on
berkeley's campus you obviously
interlibrary loan for actual books will
take some time right but the but the
journals which is where most of the
cutting edge research tends
has tended to be published was available
to you just as easily
if you're a community college student as
if you were a phd student at ucla or
berkeley
whereas in washington
what was you know unfortunately quite
obvious very quickly to us being at one
of the public
institutions in the state was in
washington had no such agreement
such that uw's
amazing first class research one library
was not available to anyone else in the
state and this is um
it's i don't know if predatory is
exactly the right word but it's
certainly um regressive
and aggressive and deeply
competitive and delusionary and it's
exclusionary and you know what what is
public education for
if not even
to
make equal the opportunity to the
research among all of the students who
are engaged in the public education
system right you know much less all all
of us who aren't at some formal
institution yeah for one thing it turns
people who
would pursue
the information on their own into
obligate consumers right right so you
have to accept a fact check in lieu of
going to check the facts yourself
because you don't have access to the
journals necessary to do it and this may
seem a small matter but um
at the moment we really need high
quality
science journalists and the problem is
this is a barrier to their functioning
because they will always be hobbled
relative to the journalists who have the
access purchased by you know major
papers or whatever yep
next question
what role does counseling and
psychotherapy play in the evolutionary
world it's my field of work and study
people are always shocked at how well it
works
well i have a little
riff on this which so far has landed
well with
people who are professionals in the area
which is that there is a tremendous
amount of good to be done by
counselors
those who are really good at it
are not good at it because of the
training the truth what we formally
understand about these things is
small but in some sense and i think i
said this to jordan peterson i our last
podcast together
the
role of counselor
which might have been played by a very
close friend or a clergyman
or something like that uh in the past
has now been
turned over to the market we now source
it all a cart from a professional who is
paid to give a [ __ ] and
that's not an upgrade
that the idea of somebody who tracks the
details of your life and cares about you
for
deeper reasons is probably a much
healthier thing and so
i guess the last thing i would say is
there's always been something
odd and
not healthy about the fact that
psychology is simultaneously
the study of the mind let's say
and also a clinical practice of helping
people in need the two things have
precious little to do with each other
and in fact we've just seen this
in the replication crisis which of
course will not be limited to psychology
but the fact that psychological results
have overwhelmingly be
been unreproducible is not a surprise to
some of us right this is difficult work
to do and the perverse incentives and
brokenness of the structure that is
supposed to filter this for only the
highest quality most robust conclusions
it's nonsense and so what
academic psychologists think they know
may or may not mean anything but it
doesn't mean that you walk into the
office of somebody who has an
understanding of people and you hear
what they have to say based on what you
tell them and that it isn't helpful but
you know those aren't the same process
yeah i think i think that's right and
you know this person um
says people are always shocked at how
well it works
you know we know
we know
one
very well and of another
clinical active clinical psychologists
who are extraordinary utterly
extraordinary at what they do and
you know part of
exactly as you say it's just not
in one in the person who we know very
well um you know her her educational
background
was cool
but i don't think she thinks it's
directly relevant either right so
um it is like i've said about bodywork
right that there is you you need to know
in the case of bodywork like it very
much helps to actually understand the
underlying physical and biological
systems
but that's not sufficient
and you might be arguing that you don't
even need sort of the background stuff
with regard to you know being an
effective clinical psychologist in order
to be a good body worker you need to
have the hands and it's not clear that
you can you can learn it but it's not
clear that it can be taught to you like
you may you may sort of have the nascent
ability to feel
what you need to feel as you're working
on someone else's body um and some
people don't seem to be able to learn it
and the same thing may be true for um
clinical psychologists and counselors
that you just you know you can either
really get into someone's head who you
don't didn't necessarily know very well
before and
also
hold yourself at enough distance
to
or you know just act as an actually good
friend as opposed to sort of the modern
version of good friend who just nods
along goes yeah yeah that's that's
terrible honey uh even if you think
actually you're doing something that's
bad for you you know so a counselor of
of course is going to be someone who's
pushing back and not not leaving you
simply feeling uh awesome in the moment
because awesome in the moment is almost
never going to be the um best
therapy for long-term awesomeness yeah i
mean this is a different realm of
literally false metaphorically true
right you may or may not understand the
underlying mechanism you may be
describing it accurately or not the real
question though is do you intuit what's
going on based on what you're hearing
and can what you reflect back cause the
person to see something that they don't
see or to you know recalibrate
their
values or how well they're meeting them
or whatever it is that causes their
life to be enhanced yes
um i don't know if you have an answer to
this but i'll ask it i rewatched your
corey interview anything new we need to
know
winter is coming
um yeah the
pierre pierre and i keep in touch uh i
will say
there is a
battle
over
the same fundamental questions
depending upon where you're standing you
know i hear people claim all the time
uh that effectively you know it has been
established that uh ivermectin doesn't
work and that it's time for those of us
who thought that maybe it did to
acknowledge that and move on and it's
almost impossible to imagine what these
people are talking about because it is
not as if some picture like that has
emerged anywhere right are there things
worth knowing yes there appears to be a
concentration of fraudulent academic
work in the middle east and that
includes iberomectin right but it's also
like the number of people for instance
that are saying
ah the anosmia postcovid wouldn't go
away and then you know ivermectin
treated it
right so anyway i guess the point is
it's still noisy what the ultimate truth
of it is
i don't think anybody knows but
pierre cory is treating people in a
clinical setting he knows things most of
us can't know firsthand right um so
anyway yes it's an ongoing interesting
saga and uh it is worth paying attention
if if it looks all very wrapped up and
clear from where you're standing try
standing somewhere else
you'll you'll discover something
interesting yeah
um
i don't know what we can say about this
but um our randomized controlled trial
is the gold standard
uh and then
he's got
two partial
references here neither of which i
recognize from you know theory
cartwright published in lancet april
2011 an example thacker published in
british uh medical journal
um or pmj is what it says something
might be bjorn i can't remember november
2021
uh are they called standard
no no um but that's
sort of a simple answer but yeah there
are a couple things going on one the
gold so first of all you need to
understand something about the
difference between systematic and random
error right systematic error sounds
less bad because it sounds not so
chaotic but in fact it's
the thing to worry about systematic
error
is errors that mislead in a particular
direction random error is just noise
phenomena that you're not monitoring
that affect your data set and the point
partially that's what statistics are for
well the point is statistics work for
random error larger sample sizes and
proper statistical methods deal with
this so you can deal you can eliminate
the influence of noise on your thinking
systematic error does not and so the
point is
a randomized controlled trial with a
systematic error built into it can
absolutely mislead you
now this is the reason that some of us
say this counter-intuitive thing about
in fact meta-analysis is superior
because it corrects for systematic
errors because systematic errors if they
are honestly made do not all tend to go
in the same direction so if you look at
multiple studies you know some treat too
early some treat too late who knows the
point is they tend to drown each other
out
and what you're left with is the signal
so but if they are honestly if they are
honestly made rather than science is
process and some force is creating an
incentive to produce studies that all
treat late and therefore blah blah blah
blah blah so
basically if you're looking at um
comparison between meta-analysis and
randomized controlled trial
meta-analysis if well done is superior
the
big thing we have to fear is uh
systematic error especially in the
context of randomized controlled trial
which seems sacred to many people who
don't understand how messy that process
actually is
but also
there are
other kinds of evidence that to the
extent that you have actually done
difficult work you know are really
important right so for example the
clinical
uh impression of doctors who have
actually treated with a drug for example
this is a hugely important kind of
evidence right it is disfavored because
it is hard to know exactly how you
calculate it but the amazing bias of
those who have used for example
ivermectin in the direction of yes this
actually does work is telling us
something and throwing it out because
you don't know exactly how to integrate
it with randomized controlled trials is
nonsense
very good
if culture serves the genes why have we
such varied religions musics etc music
music
do the same i didn't this person didn't
write music so i said music i'm going to
start over i like music
if culture serves the genes why do we
have such varied religions and music etc
do the same traits evolve in species
separate of each other why not culture
all down to environment i'm not sure
what the last parts of this um mean
exactly but the
uh but the first part is about there
being no universal best right like it
you know everything about fitness is
relative to a particular environment
space and time and
um
it is an error of thinking that has been
pretty widespread in the adoption of
sort of pseudo-darwinian thinking into
places like
um
like you know the third reich and and uh
sort of you know robber barons imagining
that because they're wealthy they ought
to be wealthy and that's an indicator of
how awesome they are and you know some
people are wealthy because they're
awesome and they worked hard and you
know but but for some people it has
nothing to do with it so indicators of
fitness are relative and that's the
short answer to why there's so many
varied cultures and musics yeah and we
specifically make the argument for
example
that monogamy is
adapted to
population expansion because it brings
all adults of
parenting age into parenting and that
polygony
is likely adapted for zero some
circumstances where making war on
neighboring populations uh
may be
advantageous which is not the same thing
as good but advantageous to the
population so the basic point is
there are two things
uh
function or maybe it's even three things
functioning at once one two populations
that are separated long enough will
adapt independently of each other even
if their environments are the same right
there's a randomness in the process that
will result in languages for example
diverging even if there's no functional
reason for them to
second thing is you have adaptation to
different circumstances which will cause
divergence and
uh anyway so
you have adaptive differences you have
arbitrary differences and the
expectation that these things oh you
also have convergences that's the third
thing is that sometimes two structures
will
converge that do the same job so i've
made the argument for example that guilt
and karma are two different versions of
a similar solution what in karma sorry
guilt
kill to the debt you pay for having done
something wrong right rather than the
belief that it's going to come back to
haunt you yeah those both discourage bad
behavior right and there may be reasons
that
they could be adaptively different or
they could be arbitrarily different but
the idea that you get two different
solutions to the same problem is not
surprising evolutionarily we see that
all the time
absolutely
yeah i was trying i was
i don't think it quite works but what
you put me in mind i was like um
with regard to parental with regard to
reproductive investment males tend to
invest prezygotically and females tend
to invest post-zygotically across many
many species and you know guilt is like
the the internal it's not a pre-post but
it you know guilt and karma are again
sort of you know internal versus
external
right and it was of something i'm not
sure it's complex too because you know
your guilt may be a proxy for the sky
god saw you do it and that's going to
count against you in the ledger and
that's going to result in you being one
step closer to the lake of fire
right so guilt would be sort of an
internalized pressure not to do that
kind of thing yeah or to fix it
um but anyway they they clearly are at
least in the same neighborhood in terms
of the problem that they solve
indeed
in an economy where incomes are ever
more stretched can we afford a true
liberal arts education is it in
society's best interest to provide it
for free or integrated into high school
education
oh boy yeah i mean the the
the financials are are
exactly very very sticky and tricky as
we were talking about and having an
endowment
um to start that allows you to be free
of you know
how do you provide it for free
someone's got to pay the faculty and the
administrators and for the campus and
for the upkeep and you know for you know
all of that
and what we've seen now is so many um
so many bad ideas
that have been instantiated in part
because of overreach of things like
granting agencies and accreditors into
the actual education
that
you know desiring
free education
um you know sounds lovely but nothing is
actually free and you know who's paying
for it and what strings does that come
with
so um you know having having a model
with um that starts with
so much
so much base funds
uh that uh that you never need
acquiesce to the demands of those
from whom you would ask for more funds
is a goal that may be unattainable
so you and i come out a little bit
different here and i have no doubt that
we could hammer out those differences
and we'd end up in the same place but my
sense is liberal arts is done
that
the core idea that it's a little bit
like
the constitutional framework
liberal arts cannot contain the thing it
needs to contain and it has already
failed so badly that rescuing it is a
mistake
that the idea
that one should be educated in a way
that provides breadth to the mind
for use later
across the duties of a citizen across
one's vocation all of those things that
is a good idea
the problem is we have not had a
conversation i have not been privy to a
conversation in our lifetimes
about given a finite amount of time in
which to educate young people
what is the optimal collection of things
that should be delivered right what is
the optimal collection of skills
exposures insights that results in a
platform a foundation to go on and be
successful and satisfied and effective
in life
and
that will have changed radically
by virtue of the fact that the human
mind
at least the human brain hasn't gotten
any bigger the human mind is presumably
constrained by the brain and the amount
that one could study has gone way up and
therefore the chaos in
an edit on what we might imbue
uh is
going to result in very different um
collections of things and so i think the
liberal arts has sort of become an
excuse
for
not
uh
delivering a coherent package
and so there's a part of me that thinks
actually
that given that there's far too much for
us to expose you
broadly across it that we ought to
figure out what it is that stands in for
the full breadth that works
and we ought to figure out how one
delivers it but we've also got a
question about
wildly unequal capacity to take on that
package based on the failure of you know
grade school of every kind you know well
but not just on the student end but on
the faculty end as well but i you know
so you and i do disagree like i i i am
not giving up on the liberal arts um
including the
uh the name you know i i was
and to some degree that may be a
semantic disagreement you know i think a
couple
couple five ten years ago a couple five
years ago i was willing to i was
prepared to just give up on the term
feminism for instance like it's just
done it's over um but i'm feeling more
now like you know what no i want the
word back and i have not
um yet been interested in giving up on
you know what i tend to say the more
complete phrase liberal arts and
sciences
because that is what has always been
meant by it
um and i do think and this is a place
actually where i think um the university
of austin project stands to um do
something really interesting that pano
canelos um the president
is the just past president of st john's
in annapolis which is the third oldest
college in the united states and has in
some ways the opposite kind of
curricular structure to that of
evergreen you know in which all the
faculty teach all the stuff but it's a
but it is a circumscribed set of things
of wisdom from the ancients and to some
degree the moderns that all students who
end up with a degree from st john's end
up um having on board and they you know
it's mostly seminar rather than sort of
sage on the stage style learning and you
know they don't tend to have you know
very much
if at all sort of natural science and
certainly not big science with you know
big instrumentation and such
um compared to the evergreen model where
uh you know you can have faculty who
really you know who really take
advantage of the model um and manage to
bring in you know lot lots of the stuff
that needs to be in the brains of people
who are moving forward into the world
and trying to make a difference but it
also allows for you know nothing at all
to have been imparted if um if the
faculty don't feel like importing
anything so i think um both of those
models actually stand um to be
potentially critical
um but
one of the big questions underlying
certainly the st john's model which i
think is the thing that you're maybe
responding to not
per se but
is okay but what are the things right
like what what are the things in 2021 as
opposed to say you know what you know
how how often are there upgrades to what
or updates
uh to what it is that is thought to be
absolutely necessary and then what gets
pulled like what what now is not in the
uh required curriculum because you just
can't you can't just keep adding because
you're not going to keep on adding years
to the college education right so this
is exactly the the question i'm trying
to point to is you've got a question of
the model and a question of the content
and i believe a model that contains
enough breadth
is essential but that no old set of
content is going to work i mean for one
thing
uh i don't exactly know when liberal
arts became a concept
you know offhand
i can't place it it's certainly it's
it's
at least mid 20th century but i think
it's before that yeah i think it's
but the sort of the you know the model
of the modern university which is sort
of you know sort of germanic and you
know it goes farther back than that but
is sort of the turn of the last century
but it seems to me
uh
no educat you know this
people will think this is me saying it
because it's my discipline and therefore
i care about it but it's quite the other
way around it's my discipline because i
thought it was so freaking important
that it took over my life but right um
the idea that people graduate from
college and know nothing about the
evolutionary process that built them
is a tremendous error right the number
of times one meets a doctor who knows
almost nothing about evolution and just
sort of takes the
you know the
the body as a as a complex mechanism
rather than something built to answer
certain kinds of
problems right
it's a terrible error so somewhere in
your in your educational experience
you need to be exposed to that thing and
that doesn't mean you know uh darwin's
model of speciation it means something
much deeper
so it should be there right as well as
uh
mathematical literacy that allows you to
evaluate claims about
you know to understand what statistical
significance does and doesn't mean for
example right
okay we got
so many good questions that we aren't
going to get to we have about 10 minutes
left
let's try to do a few fairly rapid
so this is a simple one
really really really not
um please talk about the structures
function and modification of insect
antennas the evolution of the human five
senses and human consciousness
yes
um
i i am actually super impressed that
that many things got
put into a question that short i think
it's a joke
what were the things that answered
structures function and modification
yeah of insect antennas the evolution of
human five senses and human
consciousness
yeah that's definitely a joke um
it's a good one
i like it
okay
we're not gonna okay i think there's
trust okay
okay good
chesterton's gallbladder
convince me why we read i ever needed
the damned thing oh you never did
no
don't
don't listen to him what needed we know
you don't need it
a lot of people get by without it i mean
you can make the same argument for look
let's let's take the appendix because
this is the place where we've got this
all nailed to a fairly well
right the point is do you need your
appendix no
how do we know that because lots of
people get along without it right
is the appendix
valuable
yes the appendix appears to be valuable
you could have inferred that long before
we knew what the value was based on the
fact that this is an organ with a an
expense that persists over time a
complexity an expense and a persistence
over time
we now believe we have some insight into
what it does it appears to
do something very useful much more so to
your ancestors than to you which is to
preserve a
basically an instantiation
of your gut flora so that when bacterial
so you're talking about the appendix not
the gallbladder right the
the point is when you experience
bacterial warfare that causes your gut
to empty or the flora to be changed over
to something that is not in your
interest you have this isolate that is
capable of repopulating your gut with
the appropriate stuff now the reason
that this is not
that important to a modern is that we're
so well fed that we don't really need to
be all that efficient with respect to
extracting nutrition from our food that
does not mean that this is not a
difference between life and death for an
ancestor who doesn't have enough
resources so
necessary
okay but we're trying to do quick
answers and you just talked about the
appendix which the question was not at
all about right
so the gallbladder uh breaks down fats
roughly right i don't know enough about
the ways that gallbladders fail on
people um although it sounds like from
the question that this person's
gallbladder is actually either giving
them trouble or um you know and and i do
know that sometimes gallbladders get
taken out the people yes as you say can
live without the gallbladder um but
breakdown of fat into constituent pieces
is is a
necessary part of the process of i don't
think that's what it does i think it
produces bile which emulsifies fat which
makes it more efficient for you to
access it so the reason that it's very
analogous it is yes i skipped the bile
part but you know it
but but there's a difference between the
emulsification breaks the emulsification
which gives you more surface area so
you're more effective at getting
the goodness out of the fat but the
point is you don't need it you're a
modern you've got it i would be very
careful neither you nor i have thought
as much about gallbladders as we have
about appendixes
i don't i think that's not right i
wanted to say apparently you really want
it to be right you just don't want to
answer this question i think we did i
think we did a slam dunk on this
question you probably don't need it um
but it probably has i'm not comfortable
with that answer at all i'm not i'm not
gonna say that okay i said probably
um computers use base two zeros and ones
while dna uses base four uh g c a and t
might this explains some of the gap we
see between a i and true consciousness
if so how i don't think that's the place
and i'm going to give you a secret of
the universe
the place is not the binary versus
quaternary
it's that each neuron
has a binary end the axon and an analog
end the cell body so digital and analog
yeah that there's this um this movement
between digital and analog digital
analog distribution right and there is
something
that i think we do not understand about
what is possible in a hybrid realm
now i'm sure a computer scientist will
say we've got hybrid realm yada yada
yeah or you know if you get enough
digital it becomes analog okay true get
it but nonetheless each neuron is
functioning as its own kind of computer
and it's a computer that develops a kind
of i don't know if you'd call it
intelligence but the way that the
dendrites grow and connect which then
changes the necessary conditions to fire
off an action potential down the axon
that thing is calculating each neuron is
calculating something in many cases
remarkably complex because despite what
the damn picture says in your goddamn
textbook right
a picture in your textbook has like you
know 16 dendrites sticking off the cell
body but in many cases you're talking a
thousand two thousand connections it's
amazing and really active both uh growth
and uh
apoptosis i don't know if that's exactly
what's going on there but reabsorption
and growth to new to new connections
you're talking about of the dendrites
rather than the whole cell yes
that's what you were talking about
numbers dendrites yeah right the
connections right that
it's an amazing calculator i mean that
that we've known for a while as it turns
out there is actually new neuronal
generation as adults as well which at
the point that we were in
undergrad in grad school you know that
was not thought to be the case for the
most part but um even that we now know
actually is happening but yes dendritic
growth and um not just growth but you
know the the flip side of that which is
equally important of you know
losing connections that you once had
with you know the simple version is like
you know you don't use it and you know
you lose the connection
is just as important to retaining a
coherent system yep
magnesium
helps process d vitamin d magnesium
deficiency looks like long covid
magnesium should be in the water
magnesium helps process vitamin d yes
magnesium deficiency looks like long
coven interesting i hadn't thought that
in exactly those terms but what i can
pull up from my head right away i think
that's right magnesium should be in the
water
i don't think so i don't i don't think
that putting things in our water supply
should be the way that we do these do
these things that supplementing
you know supplementing in some
foodstuffs like d is in a lot of milk
where you can also buy that food stuff
without it if for whatever reason you
decide you don't want it
or for instance fluoride in toothpaste
but not in water supply
makes much more sense all right
point of order
it is ambiguous whether they're
suggesting that it should be added to
water
or whether it should be in the water by
virtually the fact that some amount of
it tends to be in one i read this as a
prescription if it's just if it's sort
of like
even if you are um you own your own
family farm and you're growing um food
organically
there is some chance that your
vegetables are
deficient compared to those of your
ancestors growing on the same soils 100
years ago or 500 years ago simply
because our soils are being stripped
because of everything else going on in
our modern world if magnesium should be
in the water and it's not because of
hyper novelty of our modern environment
that's a different question right um a
prescription should be added i don't
think it should be added i i well let's
put it this way two things you may need
to supplement i don't love the idea of
water because for one thing the amount
of water consumed therefore adjusts the
dosage massively and so yeah it's a
mistake as a place to put it now that
said that said
the iodine in salt is something that i
don't it's possible there's a reason to
have an objection to it but it has done
a tremendous amount of good it has the
same flaw where people consume much
different levels of iodine therefore
because they'd consume much different
levels of salt but
in that case i'm not sure that we know
of a harm that comes from the fact that
the dosage is not titrated
i don't think
i don't remember i don't think we know
of a harm because the dose isn't
titrated
but i stopped buying for us since i am
the official salt buyer of the family
iodized salt some years ago and have
been buying sea salt which has more of
the other nutrients but doesn't have
iodine added in particular right um and
but you know also the sort of sea salts
don't tend to have the caking agents and
all the other stuff
um
and i don't but i don't remember i did i
did my research at the time and i don't
remember what the reason was all right i
want to take take back my position i
don't know of the harm from the iodine
but we also do know a lot of thyroid
issues which could well be the result of
different levels of iodine
and so it's quite possible that there is
the same harm there and i'm just not
connecting them
nonetheless
i think the point is
you may or may not need
to supplement on any given front
right
doing some sort of broad scale public
thing has a massive cost in terms of
titration and you're far better off to
correct a problem if you have one
and the problem could be
your water source you know if it's
desalinated
then it may have lost all of its
minerals you may be deficient for that
reason your ancestors may have come from
a place with ample whatever in the soil
and you may be living in a place in
which it's not in your water and
supplementation is necessary to correct
the mismatch but awareness of these
mismatches is uh
i think a higher priority than you and i
have realized until very recently yeah
yeah exactly okay
um
two more comments and then one last
question and then we are out for the
week
uh this just greetings from somerset uk
love you both love your work charlie
thank you charlie and it doesn't matter
how you say the word giraffe will always
look down on you
nice finally
uh we're skipping lots of good questions
here sorry for that uh guys but here's
the last question that we're gonna get
to this week as a secular parent how can
i help my six-year-old daughter deal
with death
well you know this is one of these
questions i sort of think it's almost
upside down right there's this thing
um
okay
i don't know i'll give you give you a
couple examples
a father whose
son had been attacked by a mountain lion
and the father had courageously fended
off the mountain lion and the child was
injured but pretty well okay was asked
how his son was doing
and he said you know
it's odd
uh you know he's obviously a little
shaken by it but in some sense he's so
young that he doesn't know that this
isn't just something that happens right
um
likewise
uh
in afghanistan
20 years ago somebody was talking about
these kids who
who you know had nerves of steel and you
know bombs could be going off not too
far away but because it was what they
knew
uh it didn't throw them the way it would
throw you or me
and the basic point is in some sense
you're projecting your own adult
sensitivities onto a child and children
have dealt with death far more depth
than us moderns deal with
you know that we're built for it and it
doesn't mean it isn't terribly sad and
it doesn't mean that it doesn't open up
philosophical questions and it doesn't
mean that you're as well armed to deal
with it as a parent who does have the
tools of like oh they're in a better
place but
i don't know of a child who learns of
death and is crippled by the knowledge
of it
right it's much more likely to be a
preoccupation of adults who
have been shielded and sheltered from
death until too late i think i think
that's right i'm actually just thinking
anecdotally um in our own in our own
family
my father who lived with my my mother in
the same town as us and therefore was
very close with both of our children
died when they were nine and seven i
believe and had a um
had literally a near-death experience
like heart stopped for 20 minutes
a year before and was in the icu for
many months actually and then we got a
year of life out of him um half but in
in that interim year so really that
happened when toby younger son was six
and um
there's a lot to say about this but
never
ever did it occur to either of us
to
protect our children from
their grandfather
as he was getting sicker and as he was
you know at risk of dying several times
and then you know he made it through
when he had many many many months of of
you know remarkable health before before
dying a year later
um in fact really it was almost the
opposite it was the idea yeah like we
my parents had moved up to olympia to be
with us and really to be with their or
their grandchildren
um and they spent um i think they picked
them up at that point you know from
school three days a week and they spent
you know and we spent at least one
evening all of us at their house having
dinner together but you know the kids
spent um a lot of time with their
grandparents and
um the idea that this would have been a
moment to pull back
to you know protect the children from an
understanding that their grandfather was
sick
no you know we wanted we wanted them to
to be to have to lay down more memories
of their grandfather
in case he did die which ultimately he
did
and you know that's not the
that's sort of an unhelpful anecdote um
for those who are not in the unfortunate
position of having um someone with whom
they want their child to be close who is
potentially dying near them but um
the idea being
um
death has always been more a part of
life than we moderns like to think yeah
it's been sanitized out of our life
because it's difficult um you know our
kids
uh were rushed to
your parents house when your dad had his
heart attack and we were in fact told
that he was gone and then we got a
a
a uh revised report
many minutes later that in fact he was
not gone well i might think and i've
actually i've i think i've told that
story um
maybe on greg ellis's podcast
i've talked about it on dark horse too
okay um
but i mean i think
uh you know it was early early in the
morning and my mother called me
dad's yeah
he had something heart attack they lived
i don't know eight minutes away or so by
car um i happened to be up it was like
the first week of the quarter i happened
to be up it was six in the morning
working on curriculum
and otherwise my phone wouldn't have
been on
and i i think my father would have died
because
i said okay i'm coming over and i ran
upstairs to get socks or something and
wasn't totally quiet and woke you and
said i have to go my dad's having a
heart attack and you sat up you said i'm
getting the boy i said no god no i'm
like i am going
and you said no
yeah we had and um
you drove and therefore it was you know
two-thirds the time that it should have
taken
that's the most
usual short time that would have taken
and um
[Music]
and i asked you to stay in the car with
the boys i said i don't know and there
were you know four three or four
emergency vehicles in the driveway and
by this time it's like 6 20 or something
um
and i went and the door was locked which
is weird and i banged on it and my
mother opened it and there was like
eight or ten
um first responders my dad is on the
floor my hands was a big guy and there
you know eight or ten guys working on
him and
my mother said he just told us he just
told me he's gone
and i hugged my mom
and
very shortly thereafter you guys knocked
on the door
and i don't know if it was three four
five minutes after i'd gone in
but there you were once again you know
disobeying my request to stay in the car
35 seconds
well it wasn't minutes later then
because um
you would said minutes later which is
why i guess that hold on and you came
to the door i opened the door and it was
you standing there with our two little
boys
right like six and eight
and all these all was all men all these
first responders sort of you know like
who's who keeps coming to the door at
this point right like it's 6 30 in the
morning
and
you've got these
two boys
who are standing there who clearly it's
clearly their grandfather and like
you know they clearly love him and
they'd already been working on him for
20 minutes and who knows how long before
that his heart had stopped they hadn't
been there before that and
they brought him back and they brought
him back at the point that they really
thought they had done everything they
could
i think because
you were standing there with our
children
revealing to them that this was a man
who was much loved
yeah much much loved
and um yeah it was really touch and go
for
many weeks closing in on two maybe even
more than two months after that but we
then got another year with him we did
and uh i i don't think he would have
survived had had you guys not come to
the door i think that's that's quite
possible um
it's also true that uh
when your dad finally did die
your
uh our children were there
um
and
when he was cremated
we insisted on being present too and the
point is all of those things
are
you know it isn't the natural process
but it is an analog for the natural
process in which you would have very
close contact with people in the process
of dying and then
dealing with the body afterwards and
um there's just no way we're not
programmed for this right it's too much
a normal feature of life yeah
yeah and you and um i mean i think we
have responded more to the question of
sort of how do you
how do you bring
an experience of death and a normalizing
experience of death back into a child's
life who lives lives in such a secular
world in which death has been distanced
but i think the other thing and i think
maybe we'll save this for another time
but you know the asp but aspect of the
question that we didn't get to is
how do you deal with the you know what
for many people is a terror
of um
you know permanent absence
um and that you know that too will
happen to you will happen to everyone
and that is um that is
something that religion does make easier
i imagine
yeah although i mean there's also a very
simple philosophical way of dealing with
it which is
yep that happens
you will be returned to the state you
were in before you were
and it's not bad
um
you know i mean
yeah i'm not sure
you say things like that it's not bad
really how do you know well because i
spent a very long time there
in fact i believe mark twain has
something he said about it uh
you know the equivalent of yeah it
didn't bother me a bit
well he's back there now isn't he yes he
is
and i imagine he's
okay with it
i think he's not okay with it but i also
think he's not not okay with it
easy
right there on the knife's edge between
them right yes all right i think i feel
like we were doing well and like that
last bit is just not helpful at all
what are you going to do yeah all right
but
next week i think we may be back in our
normal set
i don't know
yeah we'll see we'll see
um as long as the quail don't get in the
way
wow yeah i hadn't even considered i
thought we'd
we'd faced them we dealt with it i don't
know i feel like the quail will always
keep coming back yep yep
all right
uh be good to the ones you love
eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you